so this is a pretty interesting we've
been wondering
what direction fox news is going to take
in the post-trump era will they go more
in the direction of the non-trump
republicans the direction of people like
mitt romney and liz cheney kind of going
back to the george w
bush era will fox news go fully back
in on trump or trumpian elected
officials the sort of marjorie taylor
greene
lauren beaubert madison cawthorne
direction and there's all sorts of
considerations
one way or the other but ultimately
we're going to have to wait and see
um yesterday morning the morning after
donald trump's bizarre and dishonest
90-minute long speech to cpac the
conservative political action conference
the fox and friends morning show hosts
were sort of gleefully repeating donald
trump's
clever lies about having won the 2020
election now it's sort of like a lie
ception
type of thing one of the people they
invited on
to talk about trump's speech is fox news
host
pete hegseth now heg seth was also a
speaker at cpac
i'm going to play this clip for you and
what what i can't totally tell here is
clearly when pete hegseth the guy on the
right of the screen
reminisces about donald trump's cpac
speech lie about winning
uh the presidential election a third
time pete hegseth is definitely being
serious
when steve ducey repeats it it's less
clear that ducey is saying it as
truth it sort of seems like ducey is
repeating it
as what it was that trump alleges
um but pete seth is definitely serious
about it take a look
that's what they wanted to hear they
wanted to hear that there's going to be
a republican
in the big chair at the white house in
four years yeah he went on to say i
think right after that
we may just have to beat them for the
third time right an allusion to 2016 and
2020 because he won
this time they just took it away from it
there you go
exactly everyone in the crowd got it
right away um though it was all about
you talked a lot about the borders
so yeah i mean it it seems like steve
ducey is just kind of like repeating
what the claim
is ainsley earhart and brian kilmeade
just look kind of baffled as pete seth
was saying it but at least
for now at the bare minimum fox news
is allowing if maybe not yet fully on
board with perpetuating the lie
that joe biden didn't really win the
2020 presidential election
this is a really big editorial decision
uh to make for fox news
will fox news for the next four years
be based on the lie that donald trump
actually won the 2020 election
will fox news definitively move away
from that idea
what i think is most likely is that fox
news will sort of play with it they'll
sort of play coy and what i mean by that
is
their opinion people in the evenings
will continue to kowtow to the idea
that the election wasn't really fair
their news people
will report on the fact that quote many
people
believe donald trump actually won the
2020 election
and it'll just more or less stay in the
ether
without fox news ever taking a
definitive and clear
editorial position as a as a broadcast
outlet
and if they're asked about it fox
executives will be able to say hey you
know listen
each of our shows each of our hosts
they're allowed to have their own
opinions
they make editorial decisions blah blah
blah that's my best guess
as to what we will see on fox as of
right now and it'll serve a few purposes
one is it allow them to sort of hedge
and and have something that all flavors
of right wingers can find that they
agree with
it's also probably a way legally
speaking to avoid further
lawsuit trouble they won't have guests
on attacking dominion voting systems
specifically
but they'll generally have some hosts
continue to put out the vague idea
that many people believe biden didn't
really win in a completely fair way
and that way they'll be able to placate
just about anybody who's looking for
something that is marginally less crazy
than newsmax and oan
if you expect something different let me
know
i would very much love to hear from you
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plug-in let you give
each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches
and identity theft and it's free and
like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman